Geofencing combines awareness of
the user's current location and
nearby features,
defined by the user's proximity to
locations that may be of interest.
For example,
consider this case where there are a
couple coffee stores on this street.
As the user gets close to a store,
the app could give them
notification of a special offer.
For example, come in the next five
minutes and you'll get your coffee for
half price.
As the user exits the area for
that store, the notification could be
removed too, in order to play nice and
not clutter their notification tray.
In this case, a geofence could be
drawn around each of the coffee shops.
And, when the user enters that geofence,
a notification is triggered,
letting them know that
they're in the coffee shop.
And, when they exit the geofence,
another notification could be triggered,
or functionality, for example, to clear
any notifications could be triggered.
Now, let's take a look at
how you would build this.